you were recently up at bungee in
redmond or bellevue bellevue washington
yeah playing a little bit if not all of
rise of iron which regardless of what
you did play we can only talk about a
little bit today because there's embargo
yesterday's embargo today and there's
one on the 20th which is tomorrow
there's one tomorrow to you want so
there yeah it was one Monday I should
resign tomorrow or one today and one
tomorrow every one of them are a 10am
and it was least in September 20th next
week but I did write down what you can
talk about good huh still get me in
trouble the title yeah the release date
so I mean just like broader strokes
right now sure how does this compare
like 10 Kings obviously taken King like
revamp almost the foundation of how
destiny worked in a lot of ways but how
rise of iron what should we expect from
this as far as like what it's doing for
destiny before you know to purportedly
comes out next year whenever sure um
well first of all since it is priced at
twenty-nine ninety-nine it's kind of
like in between what you would expect of
like a taking king and like their
previous DLCs which were twenty dollars
so it's a little bit meteor than just
you know house of wolves or the dark
below but it's definitely same time less
than taking king I don't I can't speak
too much in a detail about like you know
how much it like changes from taking
king but i would say taking him probably
did more for the game like overall then
this will but this has a cool story that
you know follows the Lords of iron so
you get that kind of background story
about like you know some of the guns you
you farmed and got from like the old
iron banners like who's older like you
know that's a person that you're going
to learn about we're guylian if i'm
saying his name right so like there's
some of that background story so it's
kind of like a building up more of the
world that already exists and then kind
of going to the new social space to
which I can't talk about the social
space but I can talk about getting there
um which is kind of a cool setting
because you've never really seen the
kind of like the snowy mountain kind of
stuff that you're seeing right now
previously in destiny at least not that
I can remember it's kind of fun this is
the first mission
kind of the first ten minutes that you
go through give or take depending on how
you know slow or fast you go but you
kind of get to go up that gondola that's
been in the trailers it's kind of cool
and pretty much get to ascend the
mountain 22 were these Lords of iron
used to kind of reside there kind of
their headquarters you sure were they
were based out of and they had I spoke
to a bungee at Gamescom and they're
saying like if you can't tell already
rise Byron is very influenced by like
Game of Thrones it's almost like a
fantasy sci fi setting though which is
like a lot of things are influenced by
Game of Thrones but no like the first
image they showed off was a who's the
who's the main like Lord of iron now
Solomon salad and they show him he was a
hammer with his back to like this big
breach in a wall in the two wolves and
the motion capture dog they used for the
wolves in this the same one they used
for Jon Snow's Dyer wall right yeah dude
he's like the Troy Baker dog a video
game but yeah so you did you got to play
king the mountain the first missions
yeah the one where you're ascending yeah
up the mountain and then you're gonna
buy complete like by fighting your way
up that mountain you'll essentially open
access to that social space
unfortunately I can't talk too much
about it but it's just a dance hall
people just do in their emotes there
might be some of those new ones you
never know embargoes are screwing this
whole thing up but then there's also
remastered strikes right devil's lair
and wretched I yeah so um Siva is this
kind of like new thing that you know
they were trying to kind of keep away
because it was like really powerful but
the Fallen have essentially gotten their
hands on it and nano bots plague as
Bungie was telling me yeah so so they're
using that to kind of enhance like they
haven't totally figured it out yet but
like they've used at it like enhance
themselves so that's kind of where you
start fighting different enemies now
because they're kind of enhanced with
the seva so you'll see you know drugs do
some stuff that's a little bit different
where I think you know if you kill them
sometimes you know they'll have like
this exploding orb that will chase you
and if you don't shoot that orb you know
you and your teammates are going to get
hurt and so that's like one dynamic I
think the Vandals throw down like those
like mines that slow you and so there's
like a little bit of a different dynamic
of gameplay in terms of like the fall on
your dealing what they're not
the same as you fought them before and
the strikes are kind of the same um but
there's like twists I guess so that's
why you can call them remastered strikes
I guess because you're kind of fighting
the same bosses I'm stands like that new
one with the ogre and the kind of like
the Archon but like the epics one you
pretty much go through it the same way
you gotta fight through the first part
which is like in a warehouse area which
is like almost the same just kind of
different enemy types a little bit it
reminds me like to take in enemies there
were kind of it was like the three
factions just like redone a little bit
with taking abilities and whatnot like
The Scream throw and the what that that
without super annoying though thing that
was blind you yeah so it's kind of more
like that I mean the twists are
interesting but like I would say it's
not that different you know like sure
you know septics has like a shield now
around him that's based off of a certain
element type so there's going to be a
captain that's holding like a cannon
that you have to kill and then you can't
damage septics until you shoot him with
the you know the type of element that
you need to get the shield off and then
you you resume DPS at that point so
there are like those little twist that's
kind of like the first time I was like
oh that's pretty cool but then you know
you could do it a couple more times they
like okay yeah it's just a little trick
and that's fine I guess what about a PvP
mode I played a little bit at games Jana
so just essentially what was it skill
concealed what is it it's called
supremacy but it's essentially co
confirm so every time you kill um you
know an opposing guardian they're gonna
drop a crest is what they're called and
I guess the unique twist is that you can
kind of see the emblem of the class you
killed I guess I never really paid
attention to it was just more like oh
there's a like an Engram looking thing I
better pick that up or you can deny it
etc sure it was it's fun I mean some of
the maps almost seemed in a way design
for that kind of mode cuz there's a lot
more areas where there's like close
quarters and whatever your just really
fighting over the the crests and when I
so is kind of faster paced I would say I
don't know if those sky i think was
skyline because there's like Szczesny
bar we took a skyline last exit man so I
think we're skyline is kind of like this
exterior ring around these close
quarters inner corridors and whatnot and
that's where that's where it got pretty
hectic when you're rounding a corn
to get a dog tag yeah sorry god man kill
confirmed yeah but then yeah that that
like makes you go into there were like
there's probably three people with
shotguns waiting for you to yeah exactly
it's kind of that old thing with ecology
the same thing it's like do people bait
the the crests and have you like want to
go pick it up and just wait for you to
kill you or are people just going to
chase after its kind of that dynamic
that's not in destiny yet but i think if
you played a call of duty you're
familiar with that shirt Tyler it's fun
it's it's fast i mean i think the new
iron banner is going to be supremacy so
that's that's cool they've said that
already it definitely feels like more of
a dlc in this sense than like a
traditional expansion whereas taking
felt like a big expansion to me well it
was yeah well this still at least still
has a raid 2 will come down three days
after I didn't get to see the raid so
I'm still interested after that comes
out friday to give people enough time to
kind of get up to speed to do it awesome
yeah cool well as destiny rise of iron
the new expansion coming out will be
September 20th for a ps4 xbox one for
thirty dollars yep at two a.m. pacific
cool so that will be out in uh next week
yep you're reviewing that right I am
will be streaming like 2am i think you
and i hope i think so really high we did
it lasting stinking we had that we gotta
come up with any crap that was a crappy
bed we don't speak of that bed it all
came down to i had like this new cape on
that boosts your experience because we
were both like popping the bounties that
we had saved up beforehand I don't even
we dweet the bet got completed in less
than five min I didn't have any money at
stake I got you got me like sushi for
lunch I felt bad about it gas station
sushi it felt anti-climatic very very
much so it was like alright cool up okay
we're done with the vet guys let's go
into the game yeah at that point I was
coffee crashing what to am I think same
thing launched an AA anyway that would
be great yeah are you don't play destiny
I remember taking you tried getting into
a little bit now they're back into it no
no wanted to not your thing I want
chores I want to get into destiny but
it's I you know it is it's the loot that
I want and I like I like the gameplay
like I played it when I first came out
like came back into beta
I enjoyed that but it didn't grab me it
was just so much of a shooter without
enough narrative and it's better now I
went I wouldn't say like it's like oh my
god it's like crazy better but it's
definitely a lot it's in a way better
place than it was when you put man I
just need more time at this stage yeah
that's all there is proven that needs
you yeah I know like I'm Tribble do a
segment soon about like where they go
from here with destiny to or something
but i'll be playing with you get my
light level up to speed before i'm quite
a wild and playing last couple days get
raid ready when it comes out cuz they're
gonna be a spark of light against to get
yeah but that one you know like if you
haven't been playing or if you want to
play a different class or something like
that let's say you've been playing
hunter but you're like oh I want to play
titan for rise of iron it'll bring you
up to level 40 which is like Max actual
like level level and then it will also
bring up to 280 light level which is
like you know based off your gear but
you'll get a stick like it's somewhere
to start cool yeah so yeah a collection
though that's the $60 one cool we kind
of kept talking about it so I just
closed it out again Destin you guys have
iron $30 ps4 xbox one September 20th
keep an eye out for it